Tasha: 就是做可行性研究报告
Tasha: Is to do a feasibility study report.
Alice: 我们的预算是不是告急了
Alice: Is our budget running low?
Jake:每人500啊什么呢
Jake: 500 per person, what’s that about?
Tasha: 什么东西每人500
Tasha: What's 500 per person?
Jake:每人500的那个房间对吧
Jake: The 500 per person room, right?
Alice: 啊不是我说我说我们总体的
Alice: No, I mean overall, our total budget.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Oh, right.
Jake:总体就是我们我们还花什么钱吗
Jake: Overall, what else are we spending on?
Katrina:  我们其实主要就吃吃喝喝花了点钱
Katrina: We've mostly spent on food and drinks.
Lucia: 我们恩格尔系数超高
Lucia: Our Engel coefficient is super high.
Katrina:  哈哈哈确实
Katrina: Haha, true.
Jake:对对对对对全是身份
Jake: Yeah, exactly, it's all about identity.
Jake:身份这个没办法人是铁饭是钢嘛
Jake: Identity is crucial, you need food to keep going.
Jake:对这个这个饭就没办法
Jake: So yeah, food is non-negotiable.
Tasha: 我看附近租的好多都是哈利波特的啊
Tasha: I see a lot of Harry Potter-themed rentals nearby.
Alice: 因为这有那啥对哦
Alice: Because, you know, there's that thing here.
Jake:这些都是奢侈品项目里面的奢侈品
Jake: These are the luxuries within the luxury projects.
Jake:这些都是
Jake: These are all...
Tasha: 这好像就那一家可以
Tasha: It seems like only that one place is available.
Lucia: 牛仔裤或者假的
Lucia: Jeans or maybe fakes.
Lucia: 当然现在关键是大家好像没有
Lucia: But now the key thing is that it seems like no one...
Lucia: 就是就是我们自己的衣服凑
Lucia: Yeah, we just put together our own clothes.
Lucia: 凑不出来
Lucia: We can't match them.
Lucia: 风格统一的一套否则的话也就
Lucia: We can't get a unified style unless we...
Lucia: 是用自己的衣服也行
Lucia: Use our own clothes, which is fine too.
Lucia: 像我们之前上课的时候
Lucia: Like when we had classes before,
Lucia: 就最后汇报表演
Lucia: for the final performance.
Lucia: 就是我们老师就是挑的那种
Lucia: Our teacher would choose
Lucia: 就是大概三四十块钱的那种小上衣
Lucia: tops that cost about 30-40 yuan,
Lucia: 然后底下一个五六十的那种裤子
Lucia: and pants that cost around 50-60 yuan.
Lucia: 只不过他可能没有打过风格
Lucia: They might not match the style perfectly,
Lucia: 就那种偏稍微休闲一点的风格
Lucia: but they had a more casual style.
Tasha: 永乐店
Tasha: Yongle Store.
Jake:在哪里
Jake: Where is it?
Tasha: 不知道呀搜一搜
Tasha: I don't know, let's search for it.
Jake:高德在国内是很常用吗
Jake: Is Gaode commonly used in the country?
Jake:就是比百度地图要好
Jake: Is it better than Baidu Maps?
Katrina:  我觉得比百度好用在界面流畅上
Katrina: I think it's better than Baidu, the interface is smoother.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:哦OK好远哦
Jake: Oh, OK, it's really far.
Tasha: 好远呢
Tasha: Yes, it's quite far.
Jake:在哪好远
Jake: Where is it? It's so far.
Jake:18公里算了哈哈
Jake: 18 kilometers, forget it, haha.
Katrina:  真郊区
Katrina: It's really in the suburbs.
Jake:通州还要再开18公里
Jake: From Tongzhou, we still need to drive another 18 kilometers.
Katrina:  对通州还要开18公里走
Katrina: Yeah, still need to drive another 18 kilometers to Tongzhou.
Shure: 走外卖到了是吗
Shure: Is the delivery here?
Jake:吃饺子吧
Jake: Let's eat dumplings.
Jake:走吧吃饺子
Jake: Come on, let's eat dumplings.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 需要拼不对
Alice: Do we need to mix it?
Alice: 需要醋那个
Alice: Do we need vinegar for that?
Jake:哎要醋啊
Jake: Oh, we need vinegar?
Jake:要带带上去带上去
Jake: Bring it up, bring it up.
Alice: 哦那什么时候录
Alice: Oh, when are we recording?
Alice: 哎不对导数据呢
Alice: Oh no, what about exporting the data?
Jake:呃这个吃完
Jake: Uh, after we eat.
Jake:吃完早
Jake: After eating, it's early.
Jake:吃饺子应该不慢啊
Jake: Eating dumplings shouldn't take long.
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake:好主意我们包个饺子吧
Jake: Good idea, let's make some dumplings.
Alice: 哈哈哈真的吗
Alice: Hahaha, really?
Jake:呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Jake:不不不这个太麻烦了
Jake: No, no, that's too much trouble.
Jake:呵我们没有什么精力包饺子了
Jake: We don't have the energy to make dumplings.
Jake:对时间还挺紧的
Katrina:  还要装饰房间
Katrina: We still need to decorate the room.
Katrina:  还要排舞啊
Katrina: And choreograph a dance.
Katrina:  其实还蛮多
Katrina: There's actually a lot to do.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Alice: 有人一起上楼吗
Alice: Anyone going upstairs with me?
Katrina:  有有有
Katrina: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:嚯这这一身哈利波特吗
Jake: Whoa, is that a Harry Potter outfit?
Alice: 真的吗已经换装了
Alice: Really? Already changed?
Alice: 嗯来了一个
Alice: Hmm, someone came.
Jake:我刚刚远远一看
Jake: I just saw from a distance.
Jake:我觉得这服装到底啥意思啊
Jake: I was wondering what the outfit meant.
Jake:这你这呵呵
Jake: You, you, haha.
Katrina:  我以为你说来了谁
Katrina: I thought you were saying someone came.
Jake:刚他是
Jake: Just that he...
Jake:就是过来的时候他的那个粉色是
Jake: When he was coming, his pink...
Jake:大概到一半就是黑的
Jake: About halfway through, it turns black.
Jake:粉的就是
Jake: The pink part is...
Jake:就你这个服装很好看
Jake: By the way, your outfit looks great.
Jake:就说走吃饭去吧
Jake: Let's go eat.
Jake:吃饺子去
Jake: Let's go have dumplings.
Alice: 你最爱的醋
Alice: Your favorite vinegar.
Alice: 上楼吧
Alice: Let's go upstairs.
Jake:上楼吧
Jake: Let's go upstairs.
Jake:你们上楼收拾收拾
Jake: You guys go upstairs and tidy up.
Jake:然后把这边空下来
Jake: Then make some space here.
Jake:我就哦这什么
Jake: I'll just, oh, what's this?
Jake:我我我就测一个内餐
Jake: I'll measure the indoor dining.
Jake:我测个外餐
Jake: I'll measure the outdoor dining.
Jake:哪的哦
Jake: Where is this?
Jake:开了一个
Jake: I opened one.
Jake:我靠这么搞笑
Jake: Wow, this is so funny.
Jake:有意思
Jake: Interesting.
Jake:这沙河吗
Jake: Is this Shahe?
Jake:这是哪啊
Jake: Where is this?
Jake:这是沙河这是沙河
Jake: This is Shahe, this is Shahe.
Jake:这什么东西
Jake: What is this?
Jake:这鸿福吗
Jake: Is this Hongfu?
其他人：不认识
Others: No idea.
Jake:问问修硕去
Jake: Ask Shure.
Jake:我他妈我没去过沙河
Jake: Damn, I've never been to Shahe.
Jake:我一点都不懂
Jake: I don't know anything about it.
Jake:没去过沙河
Jake: Never been to Shahe.
Jake:一次都没去过
Jake: Not even once.
Jake:没有沙河我一点没有概念
Jake: Without Shahe, I have no clue.
其他人：大四搬去了吗
Jake:嗯大四
Jake: Yeah, senior year.
Jake:在大四我想想啊
Jake: In senior year, let me think.
Jake:我靠我不记得了
Jake: Oh man, I don't remember.
Jake:好像是大
Jake: Seems like it was...
Jake:我不记得了
Jake: I don't remember.
Jake:反正没去过沙河
Jake: Anyway, never been to Shahe.
Jake:哎帮个忙吧
Jake: Hey, lend a hand.
Jake:啊好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:我我我在这转一圈大概要花两分钟哎
Jake: If I take a lap around here, it'll take about two minutes.
Jake:你你直接开场记来
Jake: You, you start directly.
Jake:对然后大概就说一个十三点零五分
Jake: Yes, then say around 13:05.
Jake:我开始测外餐
Jake: I'm starting to test the takeout.
Jake:呃你在我房间待着
Jake: Uh, you stay in my room.
Jake:然后我转两分钟
Jake: Then I'll spin for two minutes.
Jake:之后我们把这个测就标定
Jake: After that, we'll calibrate this test.
Jake:你就标定就好
Jake: Just calibrate it.
Jake:今天是day
Jake: Today is day...
Jake:day four都第四天了
Jake: Day four, it's the fourth day already.
Jake:我们
Jake: We...
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:没问你就过来就行
Jake: You just come over without asking.
Jake:Siri Siri外边会有吗
Jake: Siri, Siri, will it be outside?
Jake:一般插了电他才会
Jake: Usually, it only works when plugged in.
Jake:好的哎呦我去
Jake: Okay, oh my gosh.
Jake:不好意思
Jake: Sorry.
Jake:我很快就能把它搞好给他搬上楼梯
Jake: I'll quickly fix it and move it upstairs.
Lucia: 我很快就能把它搞好给他搬上楼梯
Jake:您放心吧
Jake: Don't worry.
Jake:哈哈没关系没关系
Jake: Haha, it's okay, it's okay.
Lucia: 我已经改造了这个精髓好嘞
Lucia: I've already modified the essence, okay.
Jake:然后一会我们把这个都关机
Jake: Then we'll turn everything off later.
Jake:呃关完机把充电宝插到那边
Jake: Uh, after turning off, plug the power bank over there.
Jake:他还是有用
Jake: It's still useful.
Jake:有一个是有用的
Jake: One of them is useful.
Jake:对那个充电器
Jake: Yes, that charger.
Jake:坏了一个换了一个
Jake: One broke, replaced it with another.
Jake:忙啥呢这两天
Jake: What have you been busy with these days?
其他人：昨天啥也没干
Others: Did nothing yesterday.
其他人：今天早上开会
Others: Had a meeting this morning.
其他人：哦说二四招不了
Others: Oh, said they can't recruit anymore.
Jake:为啥因为人满了没钱哦
Jake: Why, because it's full, no money? Oh.
其他人：因为人满了没钱哦
Others: Because it's full, no money. Oh.
其他人：25说现在决定不了急急
Others: 25 said they can't decide now, it's urgent.
Shure:  您来了哎
Shure: You're here, hey.
Jake:哦您一直在这啊
Jake: Oh, you've been here all along.
Shure:  喜欢您来
Shure: Glad you're here.
Jake:那个帮忙看一下
Jake: Help take a look.
Jake:哎不是问问修硕吗
Jake: Hey, didn't you ask Shure?
Jake:那什么玩意
Jake: What is that thing?
Jake:那个
Jake: That...
Jake:呃冰箱贴
Jake: Uh, a fridge magnet.
Shure:  冰箱贴
Shure: A fridge magnet?
Jake:拔充电宝吧
Jake: Unplug the power bank.
Jake:每个都拔
Jake: Unplug all of them.
Jake:怎么回事
Jake: What's going on?
Jake:叫金币你猜是什么
Jake: It's called "gold coins," guess what it is.
Jake:不知道金币
Jake: Don't know "gold coins"?
Jake:新加货币啊
Jake: It's a new currency.
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn.
Jake:藏了很久啊
Jake: Hidden for a long time.
Jake:第一次穿回来
Jake: First time wearing it back.
Jake:历史一流问题
Jake: First-class historical issue. 社会问题
Jake:拔完之后不用插新的
Jake: After unplugging, no need to plug in a new one.
Jake:拔完之后放着充电
Jake: After unplugging, just leave it to charge.
Jake:下午再插新的
Jake: Plug in the new one in the afternoon.
Jake:行上去吧
Jake: Alright, go up.
Jake:帮把这个给那个路亚
Jake: Help give this to that Lure.
Shure:  啊嗨
Shure: Ah, hi.
Shure:  你摸到霉霉大腿了吗
Shure: Did you touch MeiMei's thigh?
Shure:  法律比较严格是吧
Shure: The law is pretty strict, right?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  这是韭菜饼是吧
Katrina: This is a chive pancake, right?
Jake:什么我什么
Jake: What? Me, what?
其他人：就是我离美味最近就10米
Others: I was just 10 meters away from MeiMei.
其他人：因为我冲到第一排
Others: Because I rushed to the front row.
Katrina:  那票多少钱
Katrina: How much was the ticket?
Jake:那票多少钱
Jake: How much was the ticket?
Katrina:  前排
Katrina: Front row.
Shure:  差一点成功虽然味可能不太一样
Shure: Almost succeeded, although the taste might be different.
Shure:  但是差不多差不多
Shure: But close enough, close enough.
Jake:那就更要问呗哈哈哈
Jake: Then you should ask more, hahaha.
Shure:  你长得跟跟跟哎呀
Shure: You look like, like, oh man.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha.
Katrina:  笑的跟那个老鼠一样哈哈
Katrina: Laughing like a mouse, haha.
Jake:开吃
Jake: Let's eat.
Jake:缺人是吧
Jake: We're short on people, right?
Jake:完了那就坐这边
Jake: Alright, then sit here.
Lucia: 那你走吧
Lucia: Then you go.
Lucia: 碗就不动了
Lucia: The bowl doesn't move.
Jake:好呵呵呵
Jake: Okay, haha.
Lucia: 晚上死了
Lucia: Dead by night.
Lucia: 您活了
Lucia: You're alive.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:我们也可以让碗活起来
Jake: We can also make the bowl come alive.
Jake:全是青草全是草
Jake: It's all grass, all grass.
Jake:一桌子草每桌对
Jake: A table full of grass, every table, right?
Jake:你知道为什么吗
Jake: Do you know why?
Jake:就今天是一个节气
Jake: Because today is a special solar term.
Jake:谷雨嗯
Jake: Grain Rain, yeah.
Jake:你怎么知道的
Jake: How did you know?
其他人：我刷到的公众号
Others: I saw it on a public account.
其他人：嗯但是我不知道谷雨干嘛
Others: Yeah, but I don't know what Grain Rain is for.
Jake:谷雨是干嘛的
Jake: What is Grain Rain for?
Jake:谷雨是种种地
Jake: Grain Rain is for planting crops.
Jake:要下雨了
Jake: It's going to rain.
Katrina:  不知道你这些买的都是什么馅
Katrina: Don't know what fillings you bought.
Katrina:  都是
Katrina: All of them.
Alice: 那是清明前后
Alice: That's around Qingming.
Jake:有两种
Jake: There are two kinds.
Alice: 种瓜点豆
Alice: Plant melons and beans.
Jake:哦种东西
Jake: Oh, planting stuff.
Jake:对就大概是有一批菜出长
Jake: Yeah, it's like a batch of vegetables growing.
Jake:长完了可以吃了
Jake: Once they're grown, you can eat them.
Jake:应该
Jake: I think.
Alice: 嗯主要是香椿
Alice: Yeah, mainly Chinese toon.
Alice: 香椿在谷雨之后就木质了
Alice: Chinese toon becomes woody after Grain Rain.
Jake:在撸在撸
Jake: Keep plucking, keep plucking.
Jake:这什么馅的
Jake: What filling is this?
Jake:不知道它有两种馅
Jake: Don't know, it has two fillings.
Alice: 韭菜鸡蛋
Alice: Chive and egg.
Jake:韭菜鸡蛋和
Jake: Chive and egg and?
Katrina:  有肉的
Katrina: With meat.
Jake:那就是什么
Jake: Then what's that?
Jake:芹菜什么
Jake: Celery, what?
Jake:有芹菜吗
Jake: Is there celery?
Katrina:  把醋倒这了
Katrina: Pour the vinegar here.
Jake:要醋有芹菜吗这里面
Jake: Want vinegar. Is there celery in this?
Jake:还是白菜啊
Jake: Or cabbage?
Katrina:  那衣服是
Katrina: That outfit is...
Katrina:  是租还是什么
Katrina: Is it rented or what?
Katrina:  你给个预算然后我们办事
Katrina: You give us a budget and we'll handle the rest.
Alice:我给你出可行性研究报告吗
Alice: Should I provide you with a feasibility report?
Jake:好哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 那你也得给个预算
Lucia: You need to give a budget too.
Jake:给个预算
Jake: Give a budget.
Jake:我我我估一下
Jake: I'll estimate it.
Jake:我算一算现在是什么
Jake: Let me calculate it now.
Jake:如果是买的话最便宜的是多少
Jake: If we buy it, what's the cheapest option?
Tasha: 40是买的上衣
Tasha: 40 for a top.
Tasha: 算了吧我现在看到了有一个
Tasha: Forget it, I see one for...
Tasha: 全部都是25元的一套
Tasha: A full set for 25 yuan.
Jake:什么东西25块钱一套
Jake: What's 25 yuan per set?
Tasha: 你要来看吗
Tasha: Do you want to see it?
Jake:对跳舞的衣服
Jake: Yeah, the dance outfit.
Jake:没事
Jake: It's fine.
Lucia: your new还要喝可乐吗
Lucia: Do you still want to drink Coke?
Jake:喝我来喝
Jake: Yes, I'll drink it.
Jake:来我先把这是我的咖啡
Jake: Let me finish my coffee first.
Jake:对我先把咖啡喝了
Jake: Yes, let me finish my coffee first.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你看着办吧
Jake: You handle it.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 您就是老板
Tasha: You're the boss.
Tasha: 动都不动
Tasha: Not moving at all.
Jake:是老板就说你看着办吧
Jake: If you're the boss, you just say "You handle it."
Jake:哈哈这是谢谢您
Jake: Haha, thank you.
Jake:这啥呀我去这是哪翻来的
Jake: What's this? Where did this come from?
Tasha: 但是这个是长沙的
Tasha: But this is from Changsha.
Tasha: 所以他要租三天
Tasha: So it needs to be rented for three days.
Tasha: 那三天
Tasha: Three days.
Tasha: 就是呃
Tasha: Um...
Tasha: 嗯对所以他其实是25块钱好像
Tasha: Um, yeah, so actually it's 25 yuan, I think.
Tasha: 嗯我看看他是这么写的吧
Tasha: Um, let me see, it's written like this.
Tasha: 你看18啊
Tasha: Look, 18 yuan.
Tasha: 三天
Tasha: For three days.
Jake:这个预算可以
Jake: This budget is fine.
Jake:这个远远没到预算
Jake: This is way under the budget.
Jake:呵呵其实我也不知道预算多少
Jake: Haha, actually I don't even know the budget.
Jake:但是那1,000的话肯定过分了
Jake: But asking for 1,000 is definitely too much.
Jake:500以上肯定肯定多
Jake: Anything over 500 is definitely a lot.
Tasha: 但是这个的话就是在长沙
Tasha: But this is in Changsha.
Tasha: 他要租的话可能就要三天起
Tasha: If he wants to rent, it might have to be for at least three days.
Tasha: 就只有这一套
Tasha: There's only this one set.
Tasha: 他是把
Tasha: He's...
Tasha: 还有这种
Tasha: Also this kind.
Tasha: 他好像都是40吧
Tasha: I think it's all 40, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Tasha: 这一套
Tasha: This set.
Tasha: 是吧一套两套
Tasha: Right, one set, two sets.
Tasha: 但是如果是这家店的话他就在通州嘛
Tasha: But if it's this shop, it's in Tongzhou.
Tasha: 嗯但他们家好像比较贵
Tasha: Yeah, but their prices seem quite high.
Tasha: 他说点购买就可以知道了
Tasha: He said you can just click to buy and you'll know.
Tasha: 第一套是25块钱
Tasha: The first set is 25 yuan.
Tasha: 第二套就要2550358045403520
Tasha: The second set is 2550358045403520.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina:  闲鱼是个好东西
Katrina: Xianyu is a good thing.
Jake:一染50左右吧行吗
Jake: One dye job costs around 50, is that okay?
Jake:可以吧
Jake: Is that fine?
Jake:可可行吗
Jake: Is it okay?
Lucia: 可行应该是可行
Lucia: It should be fine.
Katrina:  可以啊
Katrina: Yeah, it's fine.
Katrina:  但是哈利波特衣服一天都只要50块
Katrina: But Harry Potter clothes only cost 50 yuan a day.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Jake:然后最好是能
Jake: And it’s best if...
Lucia: 但是我最好是能
Lucia: But it's best if...
Lucia: 我们能在附近找到一个实体店租哦
Lucia: We can find a physical store nearby to rent from.
Jake:嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 因为寄过来的话有一个稍微有点慢
Lucia: Because if it's shipped over, it might be a bit slow.
Jake:是没是关掉了吗
Jake: Did it turn off?
Jake:啊嗯没
Jake: Uh, no.
Jake:没亮吗没亮
Jake: Is it not on? It's not on.
Tasha: 对挺远的
Tasha: Yeah, it's pretty far.
Tasha: 然后25块钱一套
Tasha: And 25 yuan per set.
Tasha: 那一家他居然连鞋子都配
Tasha: That shop even provides shoes.
Tasha: 配饰也都配
Tasha: And accessories too.
Katrina:  这么专业啊
Katrina: That's so professional.
Shure:  每次谢运中一来就
Shure: Every time Xie Yunzhong comes...
Shure:  咱们就开始练团是吧
Shure: We start practicing as a group, right?
Jake:对呵呵
Jake: Yes, hehe.
Jake:哈哈哈我有筷子
Jake: Hahaha, I have chopsticks.
Katrina:  没有餐具了吗
Katrina: Are there no utensils?
Jake:给俩勺子可以
Jake: Two spoons will do.
Shure:  别别别别
Shure: No, no, no, no.
Shure:  咱又不是没筷子
Shure: We have chopsticks.
Jake:行洗俩筷子
Jake: Okay, I'll wash two chopsticks.
Alice: 这是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Are these celery leaves?
Lucia: 又掉线了
Lucia: Disconnected again.
Jake:又掉线了
Jake: Disconnected again.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Jake:那就再连上吧
Jake: Then reconnect it.
Lucia: 看看应该有电他
Lucia: Check if it has power.
Lucia: 为啥
Lucia: Why?
Alice: 杨老板这个是芹菜叶吗
Alice: Jake, are these celery leaves?
Jake:呃我看一下菜单
Jake: Uh, let me check the menu.
Lucia: 新鲜
Lucia: Fresh.
Lucia: 今天是十九号
Lucia: Today is the 19th.
Jake:呃这应该就是香椿苗炒鸡蛋
Jake: Uh, this should be Chinese toon sprouts with scrambled eggs.
Alice: 这个是香椿苗
Alice: These are Chinese toon sprouts.
Jake:那就是叫它叫老味道蒸菜
Jake: Then it’s called old flavor steamed vegetables.
Jake:我不知道是什么
Jake: I don't know what it is.
Jake:我看一下啊
Jake: Let me check.
Jake:毫子杆面粉毫子杆
Jake: Haozi stem flour, Haozi stem.
Alice: 哦下面还有层嗯
Alice: Oh, there's another layer underneath.
其他人：我操上面还有一层
Others: Wow, there's another layer on top.
Lucia: 哦这种东西叫锅贴
Lucia: Oh, this thing is called potstickers.
Lucia: 那这个是什么
Lucia: Then what is this?
Lucia: 尝一下
Lucia: Try it.
Alice: 为什么没有人吃腊八蒜
Alice: Why is nobody eating Laba garlic?
Shure:  我吃糖蒜
Shure: I eat sweet garlic.
Shure:  但不吃腊八蒜
Shure: But not Laba garlic.
Alice: 为啥
Alice: Why?
Shure:  因为就是他是坏掉的
Shure: Because it's spoiled.
Katrina:  少忽悠我
Katrina: Stop fooling me.
Shure:  不是腊八蒜
Shure: It's not Laba garlic.
Alice: 腊八蒜
Alice: Laba garlic.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 糖蒜有皮
Alice: Sweet garlic has skin.
Jake:那是什么蒜
Jake: Then what kind of garlic is it?
Jake:腊八蒜
Jake: Laba garlic.
Shure:  腊八蒜他这个是就是熟的蒜
Shure: Laba garlic is basically cooked garlic.
Shure:  那个糖弄糖蒜的时候是那种新鲜的蒜
Shure: When you make sugar garlic, you use fresh garlic.
Shure:  就是那种
Shure: It's like...
Shure:  没没没烘过的那种蒜
Shure: The kind that hasn't been dried.
Lucia: 看起来像一个饼
Lucia: Looks like a pancake.
Jake:早餐示范
Jake: Breakfast demo.
Jake:饿吧
Jake: Hungry?
Jake:就在这撕了吧
Jake: Let's just tear it here.
Jake:就在这撕掉
Jake: Tear it here.
Jake:看看怎么撕
Jake: See how to tear it.
Shure:  撕什么
Shure: Tear what?
Jake:撕饼
Jake: Tear the pancake.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Lucia: 这也是香椿的吗
Lucia: Is this also Chinese toon?
Alice: 这个是茴香的啊
Alice: This one is fennel.
Jake:撕完了哎
Jake: It's all torn up.
Jake:没撕完还有一个
Jake: Not finished, there's one more.
Jake:实行认领
Jake: Time to claim.
Katrina:  我觉得吃两个就吃饱了
Katrina: I think two of these would fill me up.
Katrina:  我今天早上吃多了面包
Katrina: I had too much bread this morning.
Katrina:  今天早上那个
Katrina: This morning...
Katrina:  自己做面包
Katrina: I made bread myself.
Katrina:  烤面包大厨的感觉
Katrina: Felt like a master baker.
Tasha: 不知道什么东西
Tasha: What was it?
Katrina:  黄油面包
Katrina: Butter bread.
Shure:  昨天没吃到
Shure: Didn't get to eat it yesterday.
Shure:  我的我的
Shure: My bad, my bad.
Shure:  我的肉
Shure: My meat.
Shure:  虽然不是我烤的吧
Shure: Even though I didn't roast it.
Shure:  你应该感到很悲伤吧
Shure: You should feel sad about it.
Jake:我们几点考完来着
Jake: What time did we finish the exam?
Jake:9点半
Jake: 9:30?
Jake:10点半 10点半考完
Jake: 10:30. We finished at 10:30.
Alice: 10点半
Alice: 10:30.
Jake:快12点了
Jake: Almost 12 now.
Alice: 对就是
Alice: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:就是烤烤上
Jake: Just put it in the oven.
Jake:什么时候烤上的开火的
Jake: When did we start the oven?
Katrina:  搞探子搞了半天
Katrina: Took a long time with the scout.
Katrina:  我看看拍照时间
Katrina: Let me check the photo time.
Alice: 每根头发丝都裹裹满了
Alice: Every single strand of hair is covered.
Alice: 那个烟的味道
Alice: With that smoke smell.
Shure:  昨天晚上我还倒头就睡了
Shure: Last night, I fell asleep as soon as I lay down.
Shure:  我靠昨天晚上
Shure: Oh man, last night...
Shure:  躺那躺一会
Shure: I just lay there for a bit.
Shure:  然后就着了
Shure: And then I was out.
Jake:结果我那那一天朋友还回去
Jake: So, that day, my friend went back.
Jake:我准备两点钟躺一会
Jake: I planned to lie down at 2 o'clock.
Jake:躺到三点看个乖
Jake: Lie down until 3 and watch some football.
其他人：结果躺到啥
Others: So you lay down until what?
Jake:谁赢了
Jake: Who won?
Jake:嗯打平了
Jake: Hmm, it was a draw.
Jake:结果点球
Jake: It went to penalties.
Jake:很满意嗯
Jake: I was quite satisfied, yeah.
还好我没看
Jake: Good thing I didn't watch.
Jake:是吧你
Jake: Right?
Jake:你是曼城球迷
Jake: You’re a Man City fan.
Jake:哈兰德
Jake: Haaland.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  曼彻斯特
Shure: Manchester.
其他人：其实我是姆巴佩的球
Others: Actually, I'm an Mbappé fan.
其他人：手所以我很期待姆巴佩打皇马嗯
Others: So I'm really looking forward to Mbappé playing against Real Madrid.
Lucia: 他真的要去皇马了吗
Lucia: Is he really going to Real Madrid?
其他人：好像差不多
Others: Seems like it.
Jake:大巴黎赢了吗
Jake: Did PSG win?
Jake:就是要打皇马
Jake: They have to play Real Madrid.
其他人：那马还要打多特
Others: Then Real Madrid has to play Dortmund.
其他人：然后皇马打多特
Others: And then Real Madrid plays Dortmund.
Jake:我以前都不知道大巴黎
Jake: I didn't know PSG before.
Jake:自从我做这个这个
Jake: Until I started doing this thing.
Jake:这是我们
Jake: This is us.
Jake:我2022年的一篇paper
Jake: My 2022 paper.
Jake:他的开头就叫这个
Jake: The title was this.
Jake:叫叫panel big single gram
Jake: Called "panel big single gram".
Jake:当时一看就是大巴黎
Jake: Back then, it was PSG.
Jake:对就是这个
Jake: Yeah, it was this.
Jake:是80年代TSG
Jake: It was the 80s PSG logo.
Jake:就是大巴黎的那个LOGO
Jake: It was PSG's logo.
Jake:然后我们稍微改造改造
Jake: Then we modified it a bit.
Jake:改成了我们这个分割的
Jake: It changed to our segmentation.
Jake:就它是一个牵引分割
Jake: It's a traction segmentation.
Jake:嗯你看这个牵引分割
Jake: Hmm, look at this traction segmentation.
Jake:就就就割出来的这个logo
Jake: This logo was segmented out.
Shure:  所以这个跟大巴黎是真的有关系是吗
Shure: So this is really related to Paris Saint-Germain, right?
Jake:简称是不是PSG啊
Jake: Isn't the abbreviation PSG?
Jake:就硬凑一个简称
Jake: Just forced an abbreviation.
Shure:  就是正好这个简称是一样的是吗
Shure: So the abbreviation just happens to be the same, right?
Jake:对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:就是先出了这个名字
Jake: So we first came up with this name.
Jake:然后简称PSG
Jake: Then the abbreviation PSG.
Jake:然后我上网一搜
Jake: Then I searched online.
Jake:我靠是个球队
Jake: Oh damn, it's a team.
Jake:哈哈我才知道
Jake: Haha, that's when I found out.
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Lucia: 反应是的有点慢
Shure:  大巴黎他不止有球队
Shure: Paris Saint-Germain is not just a football team.
Shure:  还有那个电竞的队伍嗯
Shure: They also have an esports team, hmm.
Shure:  吃困了
Shure: Feeling sleepy.
Shure:  吃完就想睡
Shure: Want to sleep after eating.
Shure:  睡醒了就饿
Shure: Hungry after waking up.
Shure:  饿完就想吃
Shure: Want to eat when hungry.
Shure:  感觉人生已经
Shure: Feels like life is just...
Jake:对这才是生活
Jake: Yes, that's life.
Jake:一个life就应该这个样子
Jake: Life should be like this.
Jake:这给你们加了很多戏
Jake: This gave you all a lot of drama.
Jake:太累了真是哈
Jake: So tired, really.
Shure:  不真实我们
Shure: It's not realistic for us.
Shure:  明天床上躺一天啊
Shure: Tomorrow, just lie in bed all day.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  像只蛆一样的蠕动
Shure: Like a worm, just wriggling.
Jake:你应该给我安排
Jake: You should arrange for me.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  我靠我让你看我在床上躺着
Shure: Damn, I'll let you watch me lying in bed.
其他人：你兜着开枪呗
Others: You should shoot from your pocket.
其他人：我又看不到你
Others: I can't see you anyway.
Shure:  那我把眼镜放这块
Shure: Then I'll put my glasses here.
Shure:  然后让他拍
Shure: And let him shoot.
Shure:  我躺着就是让他
Shure: I'll be lying down, just let him...
Jake:那为什么要弄个眼睛
Jake: Then why do we need the eyes?
Shure:  人类是一个草履虫
Shure: Humans are like paramecia.
Shure:  只能进行简单的生命活动
Shure: They can only perform simple life activities.
Lucia: 哈哈哈救命啊
Lucia: Hahaha, help me!
Shure:  感觉吃的差不多了
Shure: I feel like I've eaten enough.
Shure:  我好饿啵啵
Shure: I'm so hungry, bobo.
Shure:  呸我好好饱
Shure: No, I'm so full.
Jake:哼哼
Jake: Hmm hmm.
Jake:新荣誉什么时
Jake: New honor, when...
Jake:什么时候答辩
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  这跟导师有关
Katrina: It's related to the mentor.
Katrina:  我以为是学员
Katrina: I thought it was the student.
Jake:学院要求
Jake: The academy requires it.
Jake:但是导师不管
Jake: But the mentor doesn't care.
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
其他人：因为他前几次从来没看过这个
Others: Because he's never looked at it before.
Lucia: 哇这样的导师哪里找
Lucia: Wow, where do you find such a mentor?
其他人：然后问那个老板
Others: Then I asked the boss.
其他人：我说我要不要去加他微信啊
Others: I said, should I add him on WeChat?
其他人：嗯要不要搞
Others: Hmm, should I?
其他人：他说能不反他尽量别反
Others: He said if you can avoid it, don't.
Jake:哈哈反他就扣分
Jake: Haha, if you do, you'll lose points.
Jake:哈哈哈反一次扣5分哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, every time you do, you lose 5 points, hahaha.
Jake:促进满分
Jake: Strive for full marks.
Jake:准备满分的
Jake: Aim for full marks.
Jake:准备满分
Jake: Go for full marks.
其他人：我刚只说过一次c开始
Others: I only said it once, starting with C.
其他人：给他发了邮件
Others: Sent him an email.
其他人：他回我了一切信息
Others: He replied to all my messages.
其他人：请不要联系我
Others: Please don't contact me.
其他人：联系上就行
Others: Just getting in touch is enough.
其他人：哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
其他人：我们最新的几点啊
Others: What's our latest schedule?
其他人：就20号叫中文秘称
Others: On the 20th, it's called Chinese Secretary.
其他人：嗯然后就24号叫PVT
Others: Yeah, and on the 24th, it's called PVT.
Jake:24号叫Banrary啊
Jake: The 24th is called Banrary?
Jake:PVT是30号
Jake: PVT is on the 30th.
其他人：PT 30号中间没有了
Others: PT is on the 30th, nothing in between.
其他人：21号张腿
Others: Number 21, spread your legs.
其他人：24号就是所有周边材料写
Others: Number 24, write all the surrounding materials.
其他人：这是RNG原来那个是轮胎的地点
Others: This is where RNG originally had the tires.
Shure:  那是他什么的弟弟啊
Shure: Is he his brother or something?
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Shure:  你drop的写多少了
Shure: How much have you written for the drop?
Jake:我当年毕设什么初期报告忘交了
Jake: Back then, I forgot to submit the initial report for my graduation project.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:9 对对
Jake: 9, right, right.
Jake:恶劣蕊报扣了10%
Jake: The harsh review deducted 10%.
Jake:要搞那个什么说要90
Jake: They insisted on 90.
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, yes.
Shure:  对最后90
Shure: Yes, finally 90.
Jake:全部90 对
Jake: All 90, yes.
Jake:哈哈哈为什么
Jake: Hahaha, why?
Shure:  对最后90
Shure: Yes, finally 90.
其他人：是因为你导师很好
Others: Because your advisor is really good.
Shure:  是因为人家做的很牛逼
Shure: It's because their work is outstanding.
Jake:嗯可能是
Jake: Hmm, maybe.
Jake:对没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:就就特导
Jake: It’s just the advisor.
Jake:导着好导着好
Jake: The advisor is really good.
Shure:  你这你就是你
Shure: You, you just...
Shure:  这孩子不会说话
Shure: This kid can't talk properly.
Shure:  领导都把话递到这了
Shure: The leader has already hinted so much.
Shure:  哈哈哈哎呦我的
Shure: Hahaha, oh my.
Shure:  妈呀这是为什么
Shure: Oh my, why is that?
Shure:  你们导师好啊
Shure: Your advisor is good.
Jake:为什么哈哈
Jake: Why, hahaha.
Jake:老师确实很
Jake: The teacher is indeed...
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure:  别找补了
Shure: Stop making excuses.
Shure:  明年科员都不一定是了
Shure: Next year, you might not even be an officer.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure:  哈哈你快去山东进修两年吧
Shure: Hahaha, you better go to Shandong for two years of training.
Alice: 哈哈山东
Alice: Hahaha, Shandong.
Shure:  山东
Shure: Shandong.
Shure:  我一多一分我都不要
Shure: I don't need even one more point.
Shure:  他只要给我60就行
Shure: As long as they give me 60, I'm good.
Tasha: 为什么要考90分
Tasha: Why do you need to score 90 points?
Lucia: 他考了90分
Lucia: He got 90 points.
Jake:没必要他考了90分
Jake: No need, he got 90 points.
Tasha: 他考了90分
Tasha: He got 90 points.
Lucia: 嗯哦
Lucia: Hmm, oh.
Tasha: 我还以为啊
Tasha: I thought...
Shure:  我说我要60分就行
Shure: I said 60 points would be enough for me.
Shure:  你多一分都是多给我的都没有用
Shure: Any extra points are just extra, they don't matter to me.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure:  企站是什么
Shure: What's "Qi Zhan"?
Jake:企业战略
Jake: Business strategy.
Jake:我都记得啊
Jake: I remember it all.
Shure:  不是应该不是60
Shure: Wasn't it supposed to be 60?
其他人：我整整60
Others: I got exactly 60.
其他人：我跟你们说
Others: Let me tell you.
其他人：我觉得我考试非常想提前交卷了
Others: I really wanted to submit my exam early.
其他人：这考试题我实在是真的不会
Others: I honestly didn't know how to do the questions.
其他人：然后我本来是有时间复习的
Others: I had time to study.
其他人：但那段时间繁花太好看了
Others: But the show "Fan Hua" was too good.
其他人：本来一直在看繁花啊
Others: I kept watching "Fan Hua".
其他人：所以那个真的没复习
Others: So, I really didn't study.
Shure:  我带他看哈哈哈
Shure: I made him watch it, haha.
Jake:我在那看
Jake: I was watching it.
其他人：然后考试的时候我三三十多分的交卷
Others: Then during the exam, I submitted it with a score of 30-something.
其他人：    因为我一堂课没跟你差不多
Others: Because I didn't attend any classes.
Jake:昨天哈哈
Jake: Yesterday, haha.
Katrina:  体检点我也特爱体检
Katrina: I also love physical exams.
其他人：  因为我一堂课没有去过
Others: Because I never attended any classes.
其他人：所以我不知道老师长什么样
Others: So, I didn't know what the teacher looked like.
其他人：其实那个监管老师就是我们的老师
Others: Actually, the proctor was our teacher.
其他人：但是我不知道
Others: But I didn't know that.
其他人：我以为他只是这个小小学生
Others: I thought he was just a student.
Jake:哈哈哈小学生
Jake: Haha, a student.
Lucia: 小学生小学生真是
Lucia: A student, really a student.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What?
其他人：我就直接交了
其他人：交了之后还是他跟我说的
Shure:  老师在这阴阳怪气的
Shure: The teacher was sarcastic.
Shure:  我拿他卷跟你讲啊
Shure: I took his paper and told him.
Shure:  就这种这么早交卷的
Shure: People who submit this early...
Shure:  一字不写的
Shure: Don't write a word.
Shure:  不是不是不是没写几个字的
Shure: No, no, no, I didn't write much.
Shure:  这肯肯定过不了
Shure: This definitely won't pass.
Shure:  那肯必须挂他
Shure: He has to fail.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 那最后没挂呀
Lucia: But he didn't fail in the end.
其他人：只能说老师人太好了
Others: The teacher is just too nice.
其他人： 可能看我写的屁话太多了不
Others: Maybe he saw I wrote too much nonsense.
Shure:  不不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  然后他他他说完这番话我就添两个字
Shure: And then he said something, and I added two words.
Shure:  我就咔就笑了哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: I just burst out laughing. Hahaha.
Shure:  对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  我就想想赶紧告诉他这个好消息
Shure: I just wanted to quickly tell him the good news.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  我们两个
Shure: The two of us.
其他人：我感觉我太傻逼了
Others: I feel so stupid.
Jake:学了一个寒假启程
Jake: Studied for a whole winter break.
Jake:就是啊学是学不了验
Jake: Yeah, studying didn't work.
Jake:哈哈哈担心可以一直干
Jake: Hahaha, but worrying can always work.
Shure:  他妈的
Shure: Damn it.
Shure:  我还有一门课
Shure: I still have one course.
Shure:  因为平时有一次测测验没去
Shure: Because I missed one quiz.
Shure:  就是平时小测
Shure: It was just a regular quiz.
Shure:  然后我因为那天那个实习有有事
Shure: And that day I had something for my internship.
Shure:  然后我就问那老师
Shure: So I asked the teacher.
Shure:  我说平时分
Shure: I said, for the regular grades,
Shure:  咱那个没过
Shure: I didn't pass.
Shure:  但是我总成绩过了能不能给我过
Shure: But I passed the overall score, can you pass me?
Shure:  他说可以的
Shure: He said yes.
Shure:  然后结果最后给我挂了
Shure: But in the end, he failed me.
Shure:  然后让我重新补了一遍
Shure: And made me retake it.
Shure:  平时小册
Shure: The regular quiz.
Shure:  唉就特别的耻辱
Shure: It was so humiliating.
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
其他人：有两门吗
Others: There were two courses, right?
其他人：我记得有
Others: I remember there were.
其他人：有一门平时不错
Others: One was okay.
其他人：有一门平时不行
Others: One wasn't.
Shure:  唉我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  反正他不是他自己亲口说的
Shure: Anyway, he said it himself.
Shure:  然后最后搞这种
Shure: And then finally do this.
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh.
Jake:走吧换眼睛
Jake: Alright, let's change the eyes.
Shure:  好disconnect finish
Shure: Okay, disconnect, finish.
Jake:关
Jake: Shut it down.
Shure:  完了我这又没有那个finish那个键
Shure: Oh no, I don't have that finish button again.
Alice: 我也是哦
Alice: Me neither.